So I believe that we are getting closer to
the beginning of the middle of the natural
end of Donald Trump's continued, unhinged,
baseless efforts to overturn the results of
the twenty twenty presidential election.
Donald Trump and others have continued to
insist this is going to the Supreme Court.
The Supreme Court is going to decide and the
Supreme Court is going to do all sorts of
great things for Donald Trump.
And he will win and he will get another term.
Well, the Supreme Court has finally weighed
in for the first time, and they have refused
to block Pennsylvania from formalizing the
victory of Joe Biden.
Now, as I'm sure you've heard by now, even
without Pennsylvania, if through some completely
unimaginable circumstance, Pennsylvania went
to Trump, which it's not going to even without
Pennsylvania, Joe Biden would still win.
Joe Biden has three hundred and six electoral
votes.
Pennsylvania is worth twenty.
If you take those away from Joe Biden, he
still wins with two hundred and eighty six
electoral votes.
That's six more than the 270 that are required.
But the point here is, with five days left
until the official electoral vote is cast
on December 14th, the Supreme Court shows
absolutely no interest and no willingness
to get involved in holding this up in any
way.
This was sort of, well, one of the last ditch
efforts so that you understand the argument
that was used.
Republican Congressman Mike Kelly filed a
lawsuit claiming that when Pennsylvania expanded
mail in voting in twenty nineteen, it was
illegal under state law.
That was the legal complaint that sort of
worked its way through the system since the
election.
The court very briefly wrote a rejection notice.
They were asked to throw out the absentee
ballots.
They said, we're not going to do that.
They just said no.
There were no noted dissents from a single
justice on the court.
Notice also that the arguments they've been
making about why.
This election was unfair range dramatically
in some states, the problem is they counted
the same ballots many times they alleged these
are all unproven allegations.
Some states, same ballots counted many, many
times.
Other states, Republican observers weren't
allowed to observe other states expanding
vote by mail was illegal.
Other states sending supposedly unsolicited
ballots was fraudulent in some way.
Other states, someone hid and then pulled
out duffel bags of ballots from the ceiling
or from under a table or wherever they came
from.
In some states, dead people voted in, others
people voted twice, etc., etc.
And every single one of these claims in court
have not stood up.
And it actually that it's not even accurate
to say that in court they very often don't
even make these claims.
It's really common that you'll see a Trump
lawyer on TV say one thing happened when they
filed the legal complaint to the court.
They don't make the same argument often because
they know there's no evidence of it.
Yesterday, also, a Michigan federal court
denied a Republican attempt to preserve election
data and machines for some kind of future
inspection.
So we are having a situation in which these
lame attempts to overturn the election results,
they're kind of naturally winding down Donald
Trump's two primary lawyers on this, Rudy
Giuliani and Janet Ellis, they both now have
coronavirus.
We'll talk about Janet Ellis's diagnosis a
little bit later.
Rudy supposedly is going to be appearing at
some events remotely from his hospital room.
But Trump has now lost more than 50 legal
challenges.
We're five days from the formal electoral
vote and Donald Trump reportedly might be
heading to Florida for vacation soon.
There are suspicions he won't even return
to the White House so slowly but surely without
anybody at any point saying it's over.
People on Trump's side.
I mean, we've been we've called this a month
ago and so did media outlets and states have
certified.
But slowly but surely, this entire thing is
going to kind of evaporate.
And on the basis of California now certifying
their election, Biden has formally won more
than 270 electoral votes.
The very final step is for that electoral
vote to actually take place on December 14th,
where the electors designated by each state
say we cast our electoral votes for Joe Biden
or for Donald Trump, depending on the state
that that they are in.
So we're five days from that.
And I think it will be over at that point,
although, who knows, maybe some will keep
insisting that Joe Biden won't be sworn in
on January 20th.
He will.
That's it.
And we'll have more coverage coverage of this
on our Instagram page.
You can follow us on Instagram The David Pakman
Show and of course, follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman
as well, The David Pakman Show at David Pakman
dot com.